like wish there with you step up centers
hosted at flipping soccer practice sorry
man we're in mourning I looked out my
fantasy teams again nobody fluffing
respects us with a GT front motors we're
dancing while guard bro where are we
welcome to the Florida section of grill
iron Heights
if I never noticed this place probably
because it's only for underperforming
teams at quarterback controversies and
bath salts let me give you a tour I'll
take it from here
since I'm the most Florida person you
love him yeah and I'm back over here we
have our own Hospital why aren't we
getting better guess you need another
year to evaluate me and that's what the
Jags deep breaths okay why am I the only
one who showed up we've built in 72 and
if sort of coasted since then so where
do you guys want to eat here is let's go
home you could be the Kissimmee Chargers
and play inside the medieval times we
need stars here we've been starting a
magnitude left tackle for years like
kiss my tuchus I'm staying here we just
signed a thousand-year lease making
another culture change everyone yeah
okay let's leave
hi sports fans please subscribe to this
channel or not it's okay you can also
watch more episodes here but only if you
want to sorry for bothering you